use the line segments below to create a
quadrilateral so a four-sided figure
with vertices at the following points so
they give us four coordinates right over
here so those have to be where the sides
of our quadrilateral intersect so one is
at the point zero comma nine so our x
coordinate is zero so we're at zero and
then our y coordinate or our vertical
coordinate is nine so we have to have
a ver we need to have a vertex right
over here
now the next one is at 0
negative 7 so 0
negative 7. so let me just put something
here we can later rearrange it to see
what actually makes sense
then we have eight negative seven
so
eight
negative
seven eight negative seven is right over
here it feels like this might be the
right edge so i'll put its other point
right at eight negative seven
and then finally eight comma zero
eight
comma zero
well eight comma zero
is right over here so it looks like i've
i have a point on every on every one of
the vertices so now i just have to
connect to these two and i'll have a
four-sided figure so let me take this
there
bring this one over
and then let me move this one up
and then bring this one down and there
you have it i think i've got my
quadrilateral